Oui
[Musique]
Quoi
Oui
[Musique]
un
Oui
il n'y a pas dans la ville
[Musique]
je
Eh bien, en ce moment à Séville très bien
[Musique]
et poneys
non
[Musique]
ou
deux
Quoi
[Musique]
je
les choses
[Musique]
et si
Jésus
[Musique]
Oui
est un titre et est apprécié dans son ensemble
[Musique]
Oui
à la fin
[Musique]
Oui
Si je meurs
[Musique]
extérieurement
et cela a
[Musique]
deux
et
[Musique]
Oui oui
c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
je
et coins basiques
[Musique]
et beaucoup
est là pour vous
ef
mieux
[Musique]
je
un
ce n'est plus le monde entier
ruben de concentration
dans le quartier
quand mille vivaient
[Musique]
mais notre
et que
[Musique]
je
Oh
[Musique]
nous avons mis
le chimiste
institué
gestionnaire
de lui
ré
[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi faire
Oui
un
[Musique]
deux
Maintenant ne choisissons pas ce qui sera oublié
avec leurs équipes
ce ciel de saison
par la force
[Musique]
Quoi
cette plante
nous gagnons de l'argent
je sais à quoi ça sert
obtenir une production très facile
allez, allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]